de tonte excuses et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec gwen sûr qu'il ait
démenti
voilà lala diakité le jeu avec son
papounet parce que je te laisse penser
le parti je vois comment ça se passe
alors en quoi consiste exactement à
temps plein de petits trucs en fait il
faut pas donc souhaité une balle d'être
détruits pour ce théâtre avant de
refaire s'est passé ma chère mais
pourquoi tu te la raconter
la belge est jamais remise de jardin
dans les yeux qu'il a fait aux enfers
toile à l'effet de mix de l'image ok
c'est absolument ridicule
ah mais c'est trop fort non aux attentes
j'ai rien compris à l'éolien auteur d'un
faux il saute pas cotiser mais elle
n'est ce pas je sais que tu aimes bien
je me casse pas la fine bouche je sais
pas d'où vous appelez ce moment montage
éventuellement
succès de verrouiller ouistiti doit bien
le plan d'action gagne encore un défi
avec des médailles en bronze boss
l'orbiel n'a fait pour moi score qu'est
ce qu'il fait dans les gal et je me suis
fait une entorse
c'est parfait mais rien d imposition
score shu chun pas mal au big soul de
mal en pis je tombe vous tombez nez
fermez les yeux et laissez votre
imagination frère de travail auprès des
jeunes et quatre défis avec des
médailles en bronze saluer l'acte de
vente en détail crucial jeux de hasard
ou ouais ouais je t'ai connu et
maintenant comparons ce bruit à un cris
de singe
ou alors si cette action était courte
c'est que la caméra s'est coupé court
vous voyez plus de tête très bien on va
chez le psy le jogging
c'est bon elle est morte
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler un fake
oui oh là tu vas tu as vu on a eu un
argent on est le à d'argent à l'argent
on adore 28,8 à gogo offert les bouchers
oui fois énorme
alors les gens vont encore mal et est ce
que et est-ce qu'on est des gens de
carglass et scolaires manager carglass
non car ils h 30 place et même sous
l'eau de deux mondes lives de nous
17 on allait rencontrer en a sacrément
l'aco en jeu aulas j'étais la guerre les
trois ponts dans doubt a pas du tout ma
connaissance été trouvé on a gagné je
demande à didier de mathématiques
sommation jeff patrick sébastien tu te
dédoublés au fonds de recherche vous
aussi dit non à la bo free attend
coucher les deux oui
c'était un vote rick boucher trick shots
de bouchage lui ouvre toi est bouché ou
quoi bouge toi oh ouais ouais et on est
là et il va nous manger et tu l'as
justel moi c'est bon score
allez de nombreux vendeurs du duc de
duels
j'ai mal sa fin
je veux la gagner alors on s'en fout
docteur constant tout au nom mais du
coup tu empêches de thiès c'est bon de
gagner
bon bah c'est l'heure de vous y rendre
vous y revoir au revoir
depuis j'ai l'impression que les mails
peuvent être partout à tout moment vous
dire cette pudeur phrase là
non mais le poids des mots et le bon on
connaît tous soit leur date plus que mû
quelque 1,46 vraiment sur le fait que la
crème solaire c'est important